i never imagined in my wildest
dreams that i would be successful you
live where you are
i think actors live exactly where they
are
the really good ones empathy is the
engine
that powers all the best in us i don't
really have a bag of tricks
to go to and or a method you know
i don't there are some days when i
myself think i'm overrated
she's an american actress cited in the
media as the best actress of her
generation she's known for the
versatility in her roles
adaptations in the characters that she
plays and being able to take on
multiple accents she's one of only six
actors to have won
three or more competitive academy awards
for
acting she's meryl streep and here's my
take on her top 10 rules for success
number 10 is my personal favorite and
i'm curious to find out which one you
guys like the most
i never imagined in my wildest dreams
that i would be
successful role play
action the fear is always there with
actors that you'll never work again
help me help me
that goes with the territory oh gee
where am i gonna go now
you have that fear the second job third
job fourth job
you have it all the way down the line so
each
happy event as it's happened has been
a surprise i'm not out of date am i
picking flowers for a woman a sign of
appreciation
no not at all except those are poisonous
i'm damocles with the sword you know i
really think it's up there by us
by a hair and every day it doesn't
happen i'm just
thrilled i never thought it was going to
happen to me you can't if you're an
actor
i'm really freaking here johnny why is
he here some people do i guess
go in saying i'm going to be a star
and they are but for all those people
that say that i bet there are
hundreds of thousands who say that and
are still
you know struggling where are you going
i don't know
i know a lot of uh my success has to do
with luck
i've also poured a lot of hard work into
it so
i feel in some way that i can justify
myself
you know but i'm just happy that things
have happened this way
i know about you and thelma rice
i know everything it's all here [ __ ] you
didn't even have the decency to hide the
evidence you just
threw it in a drawer hotel
motels oh [ __ ] you couldn't even pay
cash like a normal philanderer you
charged everything i mean look at this
flowers look at all these flowers that
you bought her and you occasionally
brought me home a bunch of
wilted zinnias how can you do this if
i'm such a [ __ ] then tell me
is what you do in art
is it a craft
is it a job you mean is it highfalutin
or mid-falutin or
a paycheck yeah i don't know there when
other people do it sometimes when i
watch other people do it really well
i think it's beyond an art you know it's
like
making music but at its best
for you at its best it's like flying you
know it's great
it's great and that's the part i
wouldn't give up and that's the part i
won't
give up even though i love my children
and being home and doing what they need
me to do i
certainly also need to express myself
in this way i don't expect you to
understand but you must know that jonas
has become
dangerous he must be stopped
he must not get beyond the triangle of
rocks
what do you want me to do you know jonas
i want you to find him and then
i want you to lose him how are actors
different than the rest of us
well they live a zen life it's
everything it's
very uncertain and all lives are
uncertain
but actors know it and actors because
you're
unemployed so so often and you live so
intensely in the moments that you are
working
uh that um
when when you come back to earth
and uh look around and you know
that balloon has gone and there's no
other one on our horizon so you
you live where you are i think actors
live exactly where they
are they're really good ones and that's
why they seem good
but they're really yes i think so i
think it's an authentic way to live yeah
i am an optimist i believe in the future
and people who do the ones who make
history instead of just sitting around
watching it
no they're willing to take the big risks
yes i made a decision
oh god where are all the men anymore
my father tyler prentiss never asked is
this okay
is this okay you know what i'm saying
mark
he just did what needed to be done you
said that when you
in trying to find a character you look
for what comes out of the eyes i think i
meant that in
in connection to working
i don't feel like i exist until i'm with
someone
or else yeah how important is listening
it's everything and it's where you learn
everything
um and and i always think of acting
i mean when i was applying to law school
and thinking well this is stupid
acting is a stupid way to make a living
and
it doesn't do anything in the world but
i think it does i think it does
i think it's there's a great worth in it
and the worth is
in listening to people
who maybe don't even exist
or who are voices in your past and
through you
come through the work and you give them
to other people
i think that giving voice to characters
that have no other voice
is that's the great worth of what we do
because so much of acting is vanity so
much of this is i mean this feels so
great
to come out here and sit here and have
everybody clap
but i but the real thing that makes me
feel so good
is when i know i've
said something for a soul
you know i've presented a soul
yes no oh damn this is pointless
wait a minute this is ridiculous we
can't even hurt each other we can't
inflict
pain pain i'll tell you about
pain i've thought a lot about
the power of empathy in my work
it's the current that connects me
and my actual pulse to a fictional
character
in a made-up story it allows me to feel
pretend feelings and sorrows and
imagined
pain and my
nervous system is sympathetically wired
and it conducts that current to you
sitting in a movie theater
and to the woman sitting next to you and
to her friend
so that we all feel that it's happening
to us
at the same time it's a very mysterious
and valuable resource
of the human species
and women i think access it most
effortlessly
we cry at sad movies we don't feel we
lose face or
stature or position doing it
we see a news story that enrages us and
we
write letters through tears our hearts
pounding
i've often i used to wonder
why human beings developed these
inconvenient and
embarrassing responses this
sniffling choking wet
obstruction you know the thing that
physicians and soldiers and
stock traders and journalists and
fashion models and
politicians and news commentators and
venture capitalists
all must suppress in order to work most
efficiently
i thought what possible value
function could it serve in the darwinian
scheme of you know survival of the
fittest and the strongest and the most
heavily armed
no seriously i thought why and how did
we evolve
with this weak and useless
passion intact within the deep hearts
core
and the answer as i've formulated it to
myself
is that empathy is the engine
that powers all the best in us
it is what civilizes us
it is what connects us every woman needs
makeup
don't let anybody tell you different the
only woman pretty enough to go without
makeup was elizabeth
taylor and she wore a ton
shoulders are all slumped and your
hair's all straight you don't wear
makeup you look like a lesbian
do you continue to learn yes do you
really
yeah in other words having done they had
this experience you are
better i don't know
i don't know this this was so
fun and sort of effortless that it
it didn't i think you you learn more
from the challenging things the things
that are tougher to do
in the past what was the toughest oh
sophie's choice or no um no
no no there have been tough things that
i care
i probably won't go into but
um just because just because they
i my molecules change in me according to
how
happy i am and whether and my creativity
gets um you know
what i learn every time out is how to
wrangle all the
elements that make me love what i do
and make it sort of happen effortlessly
and when it when that doesn't come
easily i don't really have a bag of
tricks
to go to and or a method you know
i don't so i come on moored and
part of that is a very good thing
because you have to reassemble
nobody knows what i'm talking about
so it's very good to have to start blank
and and figure out how to begin again
how to begin again
it's very good he thinks the right
honorable lady to
screech two mouths
if the right honorable gentleman could
perhaps attend more closely to
what i'm saying rather than how i am
saying it he may receive a
valuable education in spite of himself
many many of my friends woke up
at three years of age and said i have to
be on the stage and i've
never never had that i've always been an
omnivore interested in way too many
things
and i actually found the one profession
that fed
all my accents what is it that you
really
like to do each
what i like to do i know i
know and we are so good look at you
and i reached a point senior year when
my adjustment
felt like me i i had actually convinced
myself that i was this person
and she me pretty talented
but not stuck up you know a girl who
laughed
a lot at every stupid thing every boy
said and who lowered her eyes
at the right moment and deferred
learned to defer
when the boys took over the conversation
i really
remember this so clearly
and i could tell it was working i was
much less annoying to the guys than i
had been
they liked me better and i liked that
this was
conscious but it was at the same time
motivated and fully fully felt
this was real real acting
i got to vassar which 43 years ago
was a single sex institution like all
the colleges and what they called the
seven sisters the female
ivy league and i made some very quick
but
lifelong and challenging friends
and with their help outside of any
competition
for boys my brain woke up
i got up and i got outside myself
and i i found myself again i didn't have
to pretend
i could be goofy vehement aggressive
and slovenly and open and funny and
tough and my friends let me
i didn't wash my hair for three weeks
once
they accepted me like the velveteen
rabbit i became real
instead of an imaginary stuffed bunny
this is your third parish in five years
called
ask him why i left is perfectly innocent
i'm not
calling the pastor i'm a good priest go
after another child and another child
until you are stopped what none did you
speak to
i won't say i've not touched a child
you have the slightest proof of anything
but i have my certainty
may i ask what you're writing down did
that ballpoint pen
oh nothing it's a idea for a sermon
you had one right now i get them all the
time
unfortunate sister aloysius is quite an
unpleasant character
how did you prepare for that role yes
she is an unpleasant character
but for me the process has to do with
um being her
and being in her life and i imagine
events in her life that might have
affected
events that led her to
marry early to get out of the house
events that
after her husband died led her to the
convent
i look at the time in which she lived
this takes place in 1964
when for very smart ambitious women
there were
very limited um opportunities
this will not do it's just your june
i'll throw your son
out of this school why would you do that
if it didn't start with him
because i will stop this i had very
brilliant women teachers who now would
not be teachers
because the salary's too low they'd be
lawyers or doctors or business women
just because those opportunities weren't
weren't there for women then
so i imagined i just imagined the whole
context of
where she exists how she came to be here
but i don't know how anybody can
possibly believe that i have less of a
stake
in mothering that little boy than mr
kramer does
i'm his mother
i miss mother how thrilling
not to have it be about me
uh charlie kaufman's acceptance speech
which he just
faxed thursday night february 20th
it's been suggested that i write a
speech in case i win the bafta award
i've been told meryl streep has been
kind enough to
offer to accept on my behalf should i
win
i feel some pressure to come up with a
speech
that meryl won't mind reading aloud
i feel pressure to give her a joke but
simultaneously the great fear that i
might give her inadvertently a bad joke
and it will bomb and it will be as if i
have
spit on meryl streep
across the ocean and this after she
has been kind enough to offer to accept
on my behalf
this man is out of his mind
i don't want to do that after all she is
just great in adaptation a truly amazing
performance
oh god i'm gonna kill him i should
uh reiterate that this is charlie saying
this not meryl streep
who i find exceedingly modest maybe one
of the most
modest nicest people ever
oh i'm being set up uh again that was me
charlie so to be safe i'll keep it
simple and straightforward
i would like to thank bafta for this
wonderful honor
i would like to spank
thank spike jones
i want to thank meryl streep who i
understand is here tonight
looks into the crowd he's giving me
direction and nick cage and chris cooper
whom
i understand are not i am not here
either
i wish i were thank you very much
oh boy thank you
you know there are there are some days
when
i myself think i'm overrated
but not today
now take back the soul of dennis george
vince hutton
whom you have shared with us
he brought us joy
and we loved him well
he was not ours
he was not mine thank you guys so much
for watching i made this video because
my taruto will ask me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next
leave it in the comments below and i'll
see what i can do i'd also love to know
which of meryl streep's
rules meant the most to you what advice
struck you the hardest what impact it's
gonna have on your life
super curious to find out leave it in
the comments below and i will join in
the discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe
and i'll see you soon